[Music]
yes s masala Humason stop forma de
penser yo quando juego yo know who yo yo
momento de yahuveh dicamba cuerpo para
que la energía de mis ancestors whether
manifest arses kisi comment against a
plan o lo que yo sea tu por el deporte
es mucho amor es toda say you know
associate all-merciful a vida es esto
hasta que me pal
over 3,000 years ago long before humans
thought a basketball or soccer the
Mayans were playing a sport called
Mesoamerican ballgame which was once one
of the most important traditions in
their culture today a group of Mexicans
are trying to revive this ancient game
in our mondo is at the heart of this
movement in embrace Armando Soria a
Medeco a defund Iroquois de pelota thank
Mexico a motto spices some code in bossy
Ananda yo tengo queer secand o de su
propia picasa lo ponente hasta Sekar la
pelota poor egg medio en la línea de
fondo que ellos tienen look closely and
you'll see what makes this sport so
unique that you can only use your hips
to hit the ball no hands no feet just
your bare hips against a solid rubber
ball la pelota each other culture ma
seesaw la parte más difícil de este
juego es el initial porchetta Zetas
enema Tomas muy Grande's Mora tonin muy
muy Grande's si como tres años aramos
cuatro cheapos el año pasado con voce a
todos los Estados llamo so Cho Yas yeah
somos dc-8 estados : mean hombres regna
Maria put zip me des dqo algo de pelota
este deporte s tanto como masculino como
feminino decidimos en este de port a
llevarlo a lead on taste Rose Nolan
Arenado entonces yo me siento muy
contento K tanto como el hombre la mujer
tienen la misma capacidad de jugar este
deporte para mí es muy importante porque
es un llegado que le vamos a bahara
nuestros Nino's a nuestros hijos a los
hijos de nuestros hijos
Ultima me today say des portes que es
que hay una una portela Sociedad para mi
sueño más grandes area que estos
Covina's prudence arbic ADO's para puede
tener otro nibble economic Oh tengo una
oportunidad ah Sociedad cuando vino la
santé Inquisition few km pursue approval
este deporte sino Vyasa sido pro-v doe
por ellos lo eat afuera deporte más
famoso que fue por la ultima meta
Deportes code arizona liga professional
como es el football el deporte es más
que un simple deport a este es una Moroz
el deporte highlight as a dance this is
a game of finesse it's fast the ball go
between 150 170 miles per hour for the
better part of the 20th century
highlight was these four in my aim you
went to see it and to be seen yet today
the sport is barely know so what
happened
[Music]
highlights a sport there was very famous
back in the 40s 50s and it's it comes
from Europe Spain France in 1924 it
arrived in Miami High Line one of the
oldest of all games is taking winter
residence at Miami by storm
it's been dubbed the world's fastest
game you may have vague memories of
seeing it in a Dos Equis commercial or
in the opening scene of Miami Vice it
was an exciting sport and we used to get
a lot of celebrities that would come out
and want to be a part of it and want to
be seen at high Ally that's Benny boy no
he's one of the most decorated American
highlight players of all time he's
currently the player manager at Dania
casino it was a combination of the
nightlife and getting dressed up and
having a place to go the largest crowd
that ever visited Miami highlight was
15,000 people the arena held probably
about 12,000 it's just something that's
visually stimulating for someone that's
never seen it's addicting in a sense
I've been playing highlight for 28 years
I got to experience a good five years of
seven eight thousand people and the
fronton was so loud you couldn't really
hear your partners and it was just
awesome to play in front of a huge crowd
now the inevitable question how did we
go from crowds of 10,000 plus to a
scattered hundred on a good day I
believe it was in the mid 30s that
gambling was legalized on highlight the
wagering on highlight has always been a
blessing and a curse in the sense where
the wagering is what has kept it alive
for so long but it is kind of taking
away a little bit of the sport the
athleticism the game itself over the
years the focus has changed it's no
longer a high li arena
is a casino with a highway arena with a
poker room and the focus is mainly on
the property rather than just the sport
of highlight but that wasn't the sports
only problem in 1981 then owner of world
high Li Roger wheeler was assassinated
his murder is associated with Whitey
Bulger and the Winter Hill game and the
sport became annexed early tied to
organized crime in the public's mind
then in 1988 there was a player strike
that lasted three years it all was the
perfect storm where it started to take
some of our clientele away I don't want
it to be on my watch that high Li goes
away or fails it's a lot of fun and it's
something that I did for 25 years so I
can't just walk away looking out at the
crowd and seeing less people doesn't
deter my work ethic I'm gonna play the
same level and prepare myself whether
it's thousand people or 200 people
once the balls in air you got a move
playing the sport at that speed every
day you know is awesome I still have the
love and the passion for the game
[Music]
you're playing with and against all the
different people in the club and you
learn to appreciate them because of that
it's just a little family it's an odd
little sport and its unique it's easy to
play but hard to master
[Music]
now it's short oh the Cadieux cafe is
the only place where there's authentic
Belgian feather bowling in the United
States it's a bowling game that uses
wooden disks that you throw at a feather
at the opposite end of the length try
and get close to the feather it's
similar to bocce or horseshoes and then
it's a target sport that way the unique
thing about this one is that the lane is
convex and the ball tends to move in odd
directions you can score points by being
the closest with your color ball closest
to the feather of the same color some
people are really good right away other
people when they're going to club for a
while and I still don't know what
they're gonna do out there when they
throw the ball Cajun cafe today is is a
bar and restaurant in Detroit this
neighborhood was a largely Belgian
American neighborhood at one point when
the club started in 1933 this is a place
for recent immigrants after the war to
come over and have a little taste of
home more popular that's been than our
average attendance for bowling every
week has gone up at last 3-4 years
this is a good group of guys here you
know they're through all of all of walks
of life you something with every week
with them you bowl with them you bowl
against them and it's just a good time
[Music]
take a pagan festival chariots pulled by
bikes and a tiny Welsh town and you get
whatever this is
this story takes place in the Welsh
countryside in the town of landward land
worded flirted wells we are the smallest
town in the UK and this is Lindsay
Kettering ham he runs the local hotel in
town it's called the nayeth Arms Hotel
down today is a small farming community
primarily everybody knows everybody else
day-to-day life is generally pretty
quiet around here except on event day
the mountain bike Chariot Racing
Championship is an event that was
conceived to be part of a Roman festival
that we hold each January the rules of
the race to get round in the fastest
time possible the course starts off on a
short tarmac stretch then becomes a
rough stony road with puddles and bumps
and eventually comes back to the finish
along a tarmac stretch which has speed
bumps it's not a simple task we do
encourage people to dress up as the
Romans did as you can see people enter
into the spirit of it which is what it's
all about
ok but ben-hur style bike racing isn't
everything that this tiny town does we
do the events such as man vs. or spoke
snorkeling and it all started back in
the 70s Sano tidwell's was the center of
the pony trekking industry in Britain
and in the 1970s unfortunately the
industry went into serious decline at
that point the local
businesspeople started looking for ideas
to boost the economy and came up with
the idea of running events things that
were slightly different and unusual it's
great to see the success of the events
see people enjoying themselves and it's
great to be able to share what this part
of the countryside has to offer the aim
is to maintain the great community that
we have here even to help it grow but
not too much we don't want to lose our
smallest town status hey I hear you
Lyndsey
[Music]